what is up everybody it's Anna Mack here
for anime uproller and I think I found a
direct connection between Luffy and the
lunarians a connection which explains
why Luffy has fire-based powers what
gear 5 really is and why the lunarians
practically became extinct in the first
place I believe that Luffy possesses
lunarian DNA but it's not what you think
before we get into it thanks to ninokuni
for sponsoring this video If you guys
watch this channel regularly then you
know that I've been raving about the new
game Nino Kuni crossworld this is a
beautiful new Studio Ghibli styled RPG
from netmarble that literally just
launched the game allows you to
basically live inside a Studio Ghibli
movie it features stunning visuals
exciting gameplay and even beautiful
select tracks by the legendary Joe
hisaishi who is famous for his work with
Studio Ghibli I was lucky enough to get
early access to the game and I freaking
loved it amazing soundtrack beautiful
Aesthetics plus it's an MMO that you can
play on mobile and PC it's cross play
you can join together with other players
and create and expand your kingdoms you
can compete with other Kingdoms in
various PVP modes you can even fight for
the title of the best Kingdom on a
server against rival kingdoms seriously
what more could you ask for in a game
this game is going to be massive and
it's easily my favorite RPG of 2022.
check it out for yourself just click
that top Link in the description to
start playing right now you won't regret
it I was honestly so impressed as soon
as I started playing I can't get enough
of the Studio Ghibli Vibes so click that
link in the description finally this
video will contain One Piece manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned okay so ever since
we got the big reveal about the
existence of the lunarian race people
have been speculating about the
possibility that Luffy could be
connected to the lunarians there is a
very interesting video on this topic
from over four months ago by Marshall D
preach and that video makes some great
points that I will talk about later on
at first I didn't pay too much attention
to this Theory just because Luffy
clearly wasn't born with white hair and
black wings so I thought there was no
way that he could turn out to be a
lunarian but as I was working on a
previous video about the original Joy
Boys secret Origins I realized that
Luffy might really possess a lunarian
DNA but not through his family tree or
bloodline Luffy possesses lunarian DNA
because the original Joy boy was a
lunarian and his lunarian DNA or lineage
Factor was passed on to Luffy through
the Nika devil fruit we know that all
life forms possess a lineage factor and
if you manipulate that lineage factor
from a young age the growth of the life
form can be altered we also know that
consuming a devil fruit actually Alters
a person's lineage factor and that is
what allows them to gain new Incredible
abilities that seem to violate the laws
of physics furthermore the lineage
factor of devil fruit users and even
animals can be used to create artificial
devil fruits as both Dr vegapunk and
Caesar Clown have done sanji's father
Vin smoke judge was even able to
manipulate the lineage factor of fetuses
in order to turn them into super
soldiers and he is also able to create
clone soldiers for germa 66. all of this
tells us that the lineage Factor plays a
major role in the one piece world and I
believe that there is one other
important role that it has been playing
all along but we just hadn't connected
the dots yet after Sabo consumes Aces
former devil fruit the metamera no me it
is implied that he inherited more than
just Ace's power there seems to be
something a of Aces still within the
fruit and Sabo has inherited that
something since his actions and
mannerisms seem to become more similar
to Aces after he eats the fruit we don't
know what exactly this something is and
a lot of people have just called it
Ace's will but what do we actually mean
by a will and how would a will reside
within a devil fruit it all starts to
make sense only when we remember the
lineage factor I believe that when
someone consumes a devil fruit it is not
just their lineage factor that is
altered by the devil fruit the lineage
factor of that devil fruit user also has
an effect on the devil fruit itself and
ultimately the user's own lineage Factor
becomes imprinted upon the devil fruit
so once the user dies and the devil
fruit is reincarnated some part of the
former user remains within the devil
fruit in the form of the former users
Lin lineage factor that is what happened
with Sauble when he consumed the
reincarnated merame he also consumed
some of Ace's lineage factors some of
his DNA and that is why his behavior
became more similar to Aces it's kind of
like that phenomenon in the real world
when organ transplant recipients begin
exhibiting some personality traits of
the organ's original owner now in my
video about joyboy's true Origins I
argued that the original Joy boy from
800 years ago was actually a lunarian I
also said that the ancient Kingdom which
fought against the alliance that became
the world government was the lunarian
homeland that sat Atop The Red Line
before marijua even existed the red line
was inhabited by a race of god-like
creatures known as the lunarians they
had large black wings which allow them
to fly they had the ability to generate
and manipulate fire and they had
superhuman physical resilience I believe
that the lunarians were ultimately
defeated during the void century and
their place as the gods who live Atop
The Red Line was usurped by the
celestial dragons they then proceeded to
build marijua on top of the ruins of the
ancient Kingdom's capital in an attempt
to erase the ancient Kingdom from
history the celestial dragons became the
new gods of the red line after driving
the former gods of the lunarians to the
brink of Extinction even today 800 years
after the Great War that took place
during the void Century the world
government still actively hunts
lunarians and they offer large cash
rewards for any information that would
lead to the capture of a lunarian this
seems like an oddly excessive policy by
the world government if the lunarians
are practically extinct and if they had
been forced off the red line 800 years
ago then why go to all that trouble just
to capture every lunarian sure lumerians
are powerful but so are the Giants and
many other races in one piece there has
to be some reason why the world
government feels especially threatened
by lunariates and why they are so
adamant on capturing them experimenting
on them and eventually eliminating them
as I mentioned earlier my hypothesis is
that the original Joy boy was a lunarian
who possessed the Nika devil fruit and
this is why the world government is so
obsessed with hunting down both the
lunarians and the Nika devil fruit they
may have believed that Joy boy would one
day return as another lunarian so along
with hunting the Nika devil fruit they
also decided to hunt down every lunarian
at the same time if there is one devil
fruit that the world government would
really love to recreate artificially it
is definitely the Nika devil fruit and
if the Nika fruit had originally
belonged to a lunarian then it makes
sense that king would be experimented on
inside the same research facility as
kaido whose own devil fruit was
artificially created by vegapunk in that
facility and speaking of King he is the
only lunarian whom we've actually met in
the story and of course he knew the
legend of joyboy he believed that joyboy
would one day return to change the world
if the original Joy boy had been a
lunarian then the legend of joyboy had
likely been passed down from generation
to generation among the remaining
lunarians and if this were the case then
King wouldn't even need to have any
knowledge of the poneoglyphs in order to
know about Joy boy he would have heard
the legend of Joy boy from his own
family when he was still a child now
back to the Nika devil fruit if my
theory is correct and the lineage factor
of former users can be imprinted on a
devil fruit and then passed on to the
next devil fruit user this would explain
so much about devil fruits in general
and about Luffy's abilities in
particular why do devil fruits appear to
have a will of their own because that
will comes from the the lineage factor
of former users why did Sabo inherit
some Oasis traits because he consumed
some of Ace's lineage Factor Why did
Luffy have Firebase powers like red hawk
and Red Rock even though his devil fruit
gave his body the properties of rubber
which has nothing to do with fire
because the original joyboy's lunarian
lineage Factor modified Luffy's body
when he consumed the Nika devil fruit
why does Luffy's hair turn white in gear
5. again because the original joyboy's
lineage Factor modified Luffy's body to
give him this lunarian trait even the
mystery of the ancient Kingdom's name
may have just been solved by this Theory
why is just the name of the ancient
Kingdom so dangerous that Clover was
killed before he could say it out loud
because that name was probably something
like lunaria or the redline Kingdom and
so just knowing that name would
instantly tell you that the celestial
dragons are usurpers frauds that the
true and rightful rulers of the red line
are not Celestial dragons but lumerians
and that marijua was likely built on top
of the ancient Kingdom's lumerian
capital in order to hide the truth about
who the original gods of the red line
are there is a lot more to be considered
here and as I said earlier in one of his
videos Marshall D preach went into great
detail about how Luffy's lunarian
connection was foreshadowed very early
on in the story preach points out that
Luffy's unusually high resistance to
fire was established as early as little
garden where we see that Luffy is able
to withstand being extremely close to a
massive fire while trying to rescue his
friends from Mr three's wax Luffy
doesn't even complain about the heat of
the fire that he was using to melt the
wax but Mr three who is right there
close to Luffy is screaming in pain
because of the fire and he Sprints away
from it as quickly as possible now Mr
three is literally a candle man who
produces Flames from his hair while
using his devil fruit Powers so you
would think that this guy's body would
be more resistant to fire than Luffy's
and yet that clearly doesn't seem to be
the case preach also mentions other
details like Luffy's quick recovery from
being frozen solid by aokiji and the
incident from chapter 1002 of the manga
in this chapter we see big mom hitting
Luffy with a lightning attack but it
doesn't affect him because he's made of
rubber I mean that part makes sense but
then right after that kaido hits Luffy
with blast breath and kaido is shocked
to see that his flame attack doesn't
seem to work on Luffy either we never
learned why exactly this was the case
but I think that we now finally know
what's actually going on here I will of
course link preach his video down in the
description so you can check it out it
goes into a lot of additional details
that I can't go into here the point
point is that all of these little
details finally begin to make perfect
sense if we accept that the original Joy
boy was lunarian that his lineage Factor
was somehow imprinted on the Nika devil
fruit and that Luffy then inherited some
of that lineage Factor when he consumed
the fruit as a child so along with the
properties of rubber that he gained from
the devil fruit itself Luffy also
inherited some of joyboy's lunarian
traits such as the ability to resist and
create fire such as the ability for his
hair to turn white in year 5 and so on
I've always felt that the introduction
of the lunarian race this late in the
story would have an important purpose
and I don't mean just in terms of
General World building but also in terms
of the plot itself if I am right that
the original Joy boy was a lunarian that
the ancient kingdom was the lunarian
kingdom Atop The Red Line and that Luffy
inherited lunarian traits through
joyboy's lineage Factor then everything
begins to add up and the the
introduction of the lunarian race at
this stage of the story suddenly isn't
just an interesting World building
detail it's an outright necessity for
the plot let me know what you guys think
does Luffy possess lunarian genetic
traits because of the original joyboy's
lineage Factor was the ancient Kingdom
actually the lunarian kingdom Atop The
Red Line was marijua built on the exact
location of the former lunarian capital
in order to erase this Kingdom's culture
and architecture from history don't
forget to leave your thoughts down in
the comments below I really love hearing
from you you guys know the drill if you
enjoy our videos and you want to see
more in the future just leave a like and
comment it only takes a second but it
really helps us with that YouTube
algorithm and of course if you're new
here or maybe you watch the channel but
you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications subscribing is a
completely free but really important way
of directly support supporting the
channel you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
thanks again to ninokuni crossworlds for
sponsoring this video check it out Link
in the description as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya Space Cowboys